Why Potatoes are Called Spuds
Among other definitions, a “spud” is a
“sharp, narrow spade” used to dig up large
rooted plants.
Around the mid-19th century (first documented
reference in 1845 in New Zealand), this implement
of destruction began lending its name to one
of the things it was often used to dig up,
namely potatoes.
This caught on throughout the English speaking
world and this slang term for a potato is
still common to this day.
A false origin of how potatoes first began
being called “spuds” you might often read
is that it came from the 19th century group
“The Society for the Prevention of an Unwholesome
Diet” (SPUD), who among other things felt
potatoes shouldn’t be eaten.
Previous to the mid-20th century, while abbreviations
were prevalent in text, pronouncing them as
words was not something people typically did,
being something of a very modern phenomenon.
In fact, according to linguist David Wilton,
“There is only one known pre-twentieth-century
[English] word with an acronymic origin and
it was in vogue for only a short time in 1886.
The word is “colinderies” or “colinda”,
an acronym for the Colonial and Indian Exposition
held in London in that year.”
No surprise then that the word “acronym”
didn’t pop up until 1943.
Beyond referring to potatoes, the ultimate
origin of the word “spud” isn’t known,
first showing up in English around 1440 referring
to a short dagger, possibly from the Dutch
“spyd”, the Old Norse “spjot” (spear),
or the Latin “spad-” (sword).
Whatever the case, after the 15th century,
the word expanded from meaning “a short
dagger” to also referring to various types
of digging implements and eventually to those
tubers we all know and love, potatoes.
Interestingly, when potatoes were first introduced
to Europe, they met with a lot of resistance
for a variety of reasons, from people thinking
they were poisonous to people refusing to
eat them because they weren’t mentioned
anywhere in
the Bible.